what's up guys I'm Ryan right so today
we're gonna check out the video Shia
LeBouf - wow those kids every Friday
Saturday and Sunday they are [ __ ]
[ __ ] outside Shia LaBeouf delivers the
most intense motivational speech of all
time I like Shia LaBeouf you know some
people are kind of what-if about him but
Shia LaBeouf I recently finished
nymphomaniac volume two one of the
longest journeys of my life and Shia
LaBeouf is in it and yes you do see his
winger ding-a-ling and he's okay in the
role but more importantly you do see his
penis and kids if you haven't been able
to watch it it's because it's nc-17 but
just to give you some advice you could
just go to your parents netflix account
and it's just available right there even
the extended editions are available so
if you want to watch it and be bored
while watching sex check it out do it
just do it don't let your dreams be
dreams yesterday you said tomorrow so
just do it make your dreams come true
just do it some people dream success
while you're gonna wake up and work hard
at nothing is impossible you should get
to the point where anyone else would
quit and you're not gonna stop there no
what are you waiting for do it just do
it yes you can just do it if you're
tired of starting over
stop giving up
was interesting because I 30 with
everything he's saying but I also know
he's mocking it I've seen a lot of
inspirational motivational videos you
name it Les Brown Tony Robbins Jim Rohn
I've seen a lot I believe a lot of what
is said in those videos and I know even
Tyrone Magnus does too like he said one
point he says some people dream success
while you're gonna wake up and work hard
at it like I agree a lot of people
fantasize about being successful and if
I had that money or if only this if only
that and one thing I was thought is that
poor people have 24 hours in a day rich
people have 24 hours in a day the
difference is what you do with those 24
hours are you willing to apply sacrifice
for long term benefit he said at one
point you should get to the point where
everyone else is gonna quit but you're
not gonna stop there I think that's so
true because when I hear like successful
stories it needs to have that part where
it's like man they should have quit or
not even they should have but you could
see how if they wanted to quit like it
would be understandable because of how
hard it is man you got to like work hard
you got to make sure you're persevere
that's what will make you different from
those who actually make it is the
distance you're willing to go the amount
of work ethic you're willing to put into
it no one really gets lucky some people
short there are some people who just get
lucky but a lot of people who we say got
lucky actually worked really hard to get
to where they are one of the other
things he said was if you're sick was
starting over quit giving up that was
like really powerful actually I mean
there's like a couple ways you can look
at it it looks like one is stay
persistent because I do believe
persistence wears down resistance for
example if I go outside and intimidate
those kids they'll probably shut the
[ __ ] up after I do it long enough
later one thing I was taught was that
successful people have a list of way
more failures than successes and then I
think of this other line that Macklemore
says in one of his songs where he goes
if I could be an example of getting
sober I could be an example of starting
over so there's one way to look at
starting over it's like you go for
something
doesn't pan out you keep going that's
one way to start over but then another
way to start over is okay this gonna
work out let me try something different
let me try a new career path no that
didn't work out okay let me find
something else let me find something
else I'm not gonna make it here mines so
starting over in terms of keeping on
going that's a positive way of doing it
but if you keep just switching your life
around because you feel like you won't
make it in anything you do then that's a
not so great aversion to starting over
but yeah I like this speech it was funny
and at same time I was like I remember
some of these quotes and it's actually a
great way to impact people because if
they infuse more humor like this and
inspirational stuff it might make it
easier to remember these quotes anyway
guys thanks for tuning in if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter where if we
get enough followers we can get product
placements and normally I make some joke
about how we can get a product placement
but I'm gonna do a shout out instead
whoa okay I was gonna go to their job
okay I never do this but I'm skipping
shoutouts to go to this recent request
here a long time ago I put out a video
saying how I wanted to be on Conan
O'Brien we must have been at like 10,000
subscribers now the ambulance now
[ __ ] people are dying just
interrupting my video but he put his
picture together and I saw it for a
second I was like whoa what the [ __ ]
that is not real and it wasn't real but
it's me on the show Conan that's so cool
this looks so legit I mean yeah you can
tell it's Photoshop but it still looks
legit enough for me that is awesome man
thank you so much who is this person
Steve me can meet me at Jam well thank
you Steve me at Jam you're the bum for
doing this dude oh I see you play
ukulele that's cool it's probably
because if you played a guitar it would
symbolize that maybe you have a big
penis but a ukulele
it's yeah a little bit more I like you
kind of have like this Ryan Gosling
wannabe thing going on which I
understand I suck him off - yeah dude
thanks for the photo your rock keep the
ukulele business up because that's
really going places now